this episode is presented by hbo max
choose your plan starting at 9.99 per
month
[Music]
they've done heart-wrenching
examinations of pain and grief
meditations on america's betrayal of
black soldiers but now a marvel series
is ready to take on life's biggest
question
how long would it take for you
to do yourself
i'm not a weak tops right
loki
now that marvel's killed off its only
good villains they'll turn back in time
to pluck loki from the avengers dress
him like he's in a ska band and do a
speed run through three movies worth of
character development
i love you my sons
remember this place
but honestly i'm glad they made the show
tom hiddleston hasn't been this charming
since that pov chinese vitamin
commercial probably be a bit busy for
the next few weeks
but um
i'll make it up too soon i promise is he
supposed to be my husband or are we
having an affair either way i'm in
follow loki's journey through space and
time to escape the clutches of the tva a
bunch of time cops tasked with the
sacred duty to try and make the word
prune happen they want to personally
oversee the variance pruning the tva has
pruned a lot of these guys prune on site
no no pruning she's already been pruned
just prune it let's bail so you're gonna
prune me or he pruned her prune it prune
him she's self prone watch them clean up
the mcu timeline with a ruthless
efficiency of kevin feige murdering a
netflix series because apparently the
only version of events that's allowed to
happen is the one where a rat saves half
of existence and captain america goes
back in time to beat his own ass
take a number tommy boy because this
isn't just a showcase for one loki
there's an entire comic-con's worth of
variants to cosplay as like sylvie the
femme fatale who spent her life camping
out in various ragnaroks making it hard
for her to trust someone i can't sleep
around untrustworthy people who was i
thinking trusting you because you can't
trust
and i can't be trusted and even harder
for her to open up to the possibility
that she might just want to do herself
and i mean come on most people do
themselves every day like multiple times
a day and the timeline is just fine
trust me
there's classic loki proving that
richard e grant can make you love any
character even if he's dressed like
kermit the frog and talking nonsense for
30 minutes straight kid loki who
murdered thor but like kid thor all they
have to do is dangle a candy bar near a
wood chipper and let nature take its
course alligator loki he is an alligator
and chinese vitamin commercial loki what
you can't tell me that's not an
extremely health conscious loki variant
i mean just look how many vegetables you
made me for breakfast oh
neither
they're joined by mobius a bureaucrat
who's obsessed with loki and jetskis
which makes him the perfect partner for
the man who's also obsessed with loki's
and jet skis c jetski
then there's judge rinslayer an evil
bureaucrat who discovers that she's
actually middle management not upper
middle management like she thought
gasp miss minutes just one of many
multimedia presentations the show has to
use to explain what's going on without
your eyes glazing over
your salad
is asgard no don't do
and kang the conquerors annoying theater
kid variant journey to the hogwarts at
the end of the universe to meet marvel's
next bad guy with a thing for purple and
thrill as after five episodes of
fast-paced excitement kang plops into
the series like the architect for
matrix2 if he also did improv he can't
kill me because
i already know what's going to happen i
my design was quite naturally perfect it
was a work of art flawless sublime
tv didn't know about i knew all i had to
do was manage the floor of time
and prevent any super perfection
inherent to every human being as i
redesigned it
based on your history i have since come
to understand the answer
because it required a lesser mind or
perhaps
mindless bound by the parameters
and ages
of cosmic harmony this scene is 11
minutes long
when marvel needed to get trippy they
called up rick and morty writer michael
waldron to run the show and he's
bringing along a grab bag of wildly
original concepts like portal guns space
lizards space lizards barely escaping
planets before they're destroyed
speeches about how existence is chaos
existence is chaos nobody exists on
purpose nobody belongs anywhere
everybody's gonna die hype minds me i
presume if anyone's anyone
you're me my passion for unification you
mean stealing people's bodies summer
rude tech that's always running out of
jews
characters very precisely and cuttingly
breaking each other down psychologically
insecure need for validation would
motivate you to find the killer you act
like prey but you're a predator you use
pity to lure in your victims that's how
you survive getting drunk during big
missions you're drunk no
i'm just full but bear in mind
i'm very full and time prison you know
what they do to third dimensional life
forms in time prison same thing they do
in every other prison only forever wow
where do they get all these ideas i
guess there was nothing left to steal
from jack kirby huh
strap in for what's ultimately a small
scale series that manages to feel huge
thanks to massive animated establishing
shots like when you witness the
apocalypse of this world from an empty
crater enter an infernal nightmare
bureaucracy that stretches to infinity
now let's retire to this office and
welcome to the void at the center of
time and reality
the quick into the bowling alley
so if you're ready to be stuck with
content like a foie gras goose enjoy the
show that gets you ready for a movie
that gets you ready for the next wave of
the mcu that gets you ready for season
two of the show that gets you ready for
death and as long as they keep making
b-plus content while keeping every good
actor from doing anything original this
machine is going to keep cranking until
we're all in water world darkest
timeline
starring
low-key on god
be a lady tonight
the setting crashers bf kangs the old
guard
he who rehashes
gators will say it's fake dramatic
weapon achieving for my next trick
love
is a dagger find a way back to the tv
betrayals i never stabbing her in the
back that's such a boring form of
betrayal judge wren slayer really feel
betrayed by her beloved tba i guess you
don't do partners unless of course it
benefits you and you intend to betray
them at some point how do i know that in
the final moments you won't betray me
you betrayed me no no you betrayed me
you betrayed me you betrayed me oh grow
up you grow up apologies my leash i
betrayed you about that
you can't be serious my throne about
that and hair flips
chrono trigger
you know this never would have happened
if tony stark had just let hulk use the
elevator he really is responsible for
every bad thing in this universe
this episode is presented by hbo max
choose your plan starting at 9.99 per
month
i am the voice of honest trailers and i
am burdened with glorious purpose
all i ever wanted in this world was
carnage
snappy new slim jim oh yeah